[SPEAKER_01]: So, 6th, 7th, The Whale Sun, Merrick kind of thinks about the day.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you think is going on?
[SPEAKER_01]: What do I think about the day so far?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you have any questions for me?
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I'm just a little confused when it comes to the politically... because I know my mission.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's your mission?
[SPEAKER_00]: I was told to go with Owen to get as much information as I could from...
[SPEAKER_00]: I forgot who my leader was.
[SPEAKER_01]: From Jameis.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jameis, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: To go find out as much information as I could about some stuff that was going on with the whole principalities and what's, you know... What have you figured out?
[SPEAKER_00]: At this point...
[SPEAKER_00]: Besides that Toli has either... he has the amulet and is controlling the... An artifact.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's not an amulet, it's an artifact.
[SPEAKER_00]: An artifact that's controlling these turtle dragons and blocking off our coastline, causing them the mysterious storms that we've been seeing and stuff and all this...
[SPEAKER_00]: I know this information.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I know that this, where we are right now, Red Shore, right, is blocked off of the brigade and kind of keeping these merchants and stuff, people here, hostile, kind of like, not hostage, but like, they don't love being here type of thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's an embargo.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're being routed here and their stores are routed.
[SPEAKER_00]: The blockade, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I know that.
[SPEAKER_01]: And you know the Monmurgian fleet hasn't been able to break it, because why?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, well, because they can't really get through here.
[SPEAKER_00]: They don't know what's going on.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, I feel like they wanted to go as far around as we did with Owen, but the main shot is all blocked off of the storms and all that's going on over there.
[SPEAKER_00]: And anyone who's coming here
[SPEAKER_00]: Probably isn't really going to leave too easily from this area.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what I know so far of the mission.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, if they try to make it to Monmurg, they'll be redirected.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then also Caintoli, who by the way, headed east, and you saw him heading east two days ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is controlling these turtle dragons.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that's the only advantage they have over the Monmurgian fleet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it seems to be a pretty big advantage.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's huge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: But what does that tell you about Red Shore?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not really piecing these things together.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's vulnerable.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Vulnerable to
[SPEAKER_01]: Kain Tully is not around with his Turtle Dragons.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's going to stop the Monmurg and Fleet from wiping these Three-Man-O-War off them out?
[SPEAKER_00]: I see what you mean.
[SPEAKER_00]: If we took him around the other way, because there's still a blockade going, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: That's where I'm confused.
[SPEAKER_00]: If he had the artifact and he got like, okay, you guys stay here, you turtle dragons stay here, and you guys are going to cause this stir, some of you are going to guard my stuff, I'm going to head out, or am I going to be following him as my... Well, here's the thing about a ranger.
[SPEAKER_01]: They have this ability to spin the first level spell slot and see if there is a dragon, undead, aberrations, whatever, within one mile of where they are.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unless it's their favorite terrain, which is they can look six miles away.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you could literally walk up and down the coast of this place and see if there are any turtle dragons anywhere in the area.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now the problem is...
[SPEAKER_01]: How do you get in contact with Jameis?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the truth is this.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your mission has already succeeded.
[SPEAKER_01]: The mission that was given to you by Jameis and to gouging you by Jameis was figure out what Owen Black knows.
[SPEAKER_01]: He knows way too much and he told Folsom way too much.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: And actually this comes back to why Owen Black tried to have you guys killed.
[SPEAKER_01]: He realized he told Fulsome way too much.
[SPEAKER_01]: Got it.
[SPEAKER_01]: And he was like, holy shit, if Kane totally figures out what these guys, I told these guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: He figured out you were a spy, basically.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: That makes sense.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I think my best interest is to get us off this place and report to Jameis, because we're kind of sitting ducks here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I mean, you're behind enemy lines, basically.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: And everyone knows our faces.
[SPEAKER_00]: Either it's the Toli people, or it's the guards and stuff.
[SPEAKER_01]: Not everyone knows your face, and you can blend in, but there are spies everywhere.
[SPEAKER_01]: And if there was somebody that was told to look out for four dudes, and one of them is a hard-drinking gouge... Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, he sticks out like a sore thumb.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Folsom's antics seem to stick out, too.
[SPEAKER_01]: Folsom's antics, and actually Tyrus' antics, too, are not...
[SPEAKER_01]: Discreet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Discreet, either.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: So...
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Got it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Any questions?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_00]: I just know...
[SPEAKER_00]: I think I know what I'm gonna say, though.